we are here with the amazing women from
and just like that nicole karen sarita
okay i'm wondering if i can as a last
round play a little game with you um
um and do a round robin um rapid style
will you do that with me yeah yeah all
right it's time for the final five
[Applause]
[Music]
okay i'm so excited okay uh
nicole uh what never fails to make you
laugh
my kids and my dogs
yeah
karen my daughter my kids my daughter is
a clown she's hilarious yeah hilarious
my daughter dry humor catherine tate
british comedian oh
um what is your favorite chore nicole
ooh
laundry me too yeah i like ironing too
it's very old-fashioned i know gosh i
need you to come over to my house
i can shine shoes too oh i went to nyu
with a shoe shine kit yeah that's on the
gate at my house later here
i like to mop floors
i really do not like a dirty floor i
like to sweep and then i like to i've
stayed up until two in the morning
mopping all the floors in my house and
lana says next to godly yes
washing dishes is the only thing i can
do and i do it
your house is better off for it i feel
like my dishes are constantly piled up
in the sink okay nicole worst date you
ever had
ah
oh it's been so long
i don't know i can't think of one
back in another date i ever had was i
went out with a guy who was a little bit
older than me and by little i mean a lot
at the end of the day he stood up and he
had this little
you know new york times at his hand and
he hit his knee and was like well
that's that and i was like oh no
grandpa we can't go out anymore
i am second it was like it was like
yeah that was a good date and i was like
no it wasn't
you're like charlie oh yeah
i don't be honest
i shouldn't say so i went on a date with
a famous musician
and we went to a club and we were in the
vip section and he didn't talk to me all
night
worst date ever
he apologized much later oh good i love
listen women love closure we live for it
yes ben it's true um okay favorite uh
currently binging or watching a show
i'm caught up on the morning show ladies
and
gentlemen and uh yeah and uh harlem
yes
i been to watch harlem okay i'm gonna
check that out yes i just put i put out
watch lists i like to watch everything
expand my hair you're going
to die it's so good okay yes watching it
thank you yes karen i love megan good um
queer eye
the best oh it's such a good show isn't
it this season in austin so feel good
and austin oh yeah feel good so lately
i've been googling best independent
indian movies catching up on
my country and two i'm re-watching may i
destroy you
it's the best it's the best it's the
best if anyone hasn't seen me i destroy
you please watch it immediately she's
great okay um are you a carrie miranda a
charlotte or a samantha
i'm all of them that's the point
well karen um
i gotta say um i'm anaya ltwc my chain
what an answer yes i know and you know
what i am i am i've got great art um i i
i have a mercedes
and um and
i mean jay
they're good in bed i'm good in bed what
can i say i'm proud
i love i love that she i love the rambo
grandma right gosh sarita
i mean
i'm a carrie
oh oh yeah yeah
yeah well you guys have um
picked up this mantle and torch and you
have just run with it and i just
appreciate you and celebrate you so much
nicole ari parker karen pittman and
sarita choudhury
thank you so much and just like that
is available on hbo max and thank you
for putting it out into the world
[Music]